bonjour je vais vous proposer un petit
voyage de 18 minutes
on va sortir complètement de la terre on
va aller dans les étoiles pour les
prochains donc restez bien assis
on va se promener on va rêver pour quoi
aller dans les étoiles on va essayer de
trouver de la vie aujourd'hui
le premier chapitre pour essayer de
trouver de la vie dans l'univers
c'est assez y est de trouver des
exoplanètes
il faut que la vie habitent quelque part
donc je vais commencer le premier
chapitre sur les exoplanètes notre bon
vieux système solaire comprend huit
planètes vous les connaissez bien
vous pouvez sortir par un ciel étoilé et
voir jupiter saturne mars avec vos yeux
aucun problème et on a aussi des
planètes naines comme planète pluton et
ses rêves on a des lunes dit me dépanner
milliers mais des centaines de lune
seulement jupiter à environ 65 lune
tout ce beau monde orbite autour de
notre système solaire nous tenons tout
ce beau monde en orbite autour de notre
étoile le soleil sacré notre système
solaire c'est les planètes on les
analyse et on en voyait descendre dans
les zones étudiées comme il faut sans
aucun problème sauf les planètes qui
sont petit peu plus loin comme la
planète pluton c'est relativement
difficile voici les plats l'image la
plus précise qui est arrivé il y à trois
jours seulement de la dune sombre qui
est parti il ya neuf ans ça fait neuf
ans qu'elle voyage pour aller prendre
une photo de la planète pluton et elle
va arriver elle m'a avoir une photo
précise le 14 juillet prochain
c'est une sonde américaine mais à
l'arrivée sur l'un pour la fête des
français
c'est là semble la plus rapide qu'on n'a
jamais construit
on ne jamais envoyer d'objets aussi
rapide dans l'espace donc essayez
d'imaginer si je veux utiliser cette
somme là pour aller sonder une autre
étoile seulement l'étoile la plus proche
de nous la sonde va prendre 80 mille ans
pour s'y rendre
80 milles 1 c'est inimaginable on ne
peut pas utiliser ce genre d'appareil
peut sonder les autres qu'est ce qu'on
va faire naître et toi notre soleil
c'est une étoile parmi des milliards de
milliards d'autres ici il y à des
planètes autour de notre soleil il y a
sûrement des planètes autour des autres
étoiles c'est une question probabilité
on n'est pas unique dans l'univers
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va
utiliser des télescopes et des
techniques sur terre on va s'y
développer ce genre de technique là
qu'est ce qui rend l'observation
vraiment difficile
regardez ici j'ai un système une
simulation une étoile comme la planète
terre et on va arriver avec pas une
étoile une planète comme la planète
terre est une autre planète comme la
planète jupiter qui embête au tour d'un
autre soleil cancon et les regarde de la
terre bientôt on s'aperçoit que les
planètes sont tellement collé sur leur
étoile qui est pratiquement impossible
de les distinguer j'ai pratiquement
impossible mais pas impossible
aussi les toiles et des millions de fois
plus lumineuse que les planeurs donc
c'est très difficile à les voir bon vous
êtes dans les sciences molles maintenant
je vais vous faire un petit cours de
physique un petit cours dans les
sciences dures pour la peur la prochaine
minutes seulement
la spectroscopie c'est la clé de voûte
pour la recherche des exoplanètes
si on comprend la swisscoy de la
spectroscopie on va être capable de
comprendre comment on fait la recherche
des exoplanètes une des techniques
la spectroscopie et la photographie ici
on y voit dans ma cuisine
j'ai plafonnier de ma cuisine et de
lumière quelqu'un peut me dire si je
suis écologique que les miens
fluocompactes ou si je suis de la
vieille école avec des lumières rien
qu'en décembre
le physicien bobo dit je vais créer un
suspect je vais prendre le spectre de
l'étoile de la lumière et je vais
pouvoir dire quel type de lumière c'est
celle de gauche
inspec tout à fait standard un arc en
ciel rien de spécial pour un physicien
c'est comme si j'avais chauffer une
roche celle de droite présente quelque
chose de spécial hello débit bande de
couleur foncée et des bandes de couleurs
par des petits traits qu'on appelle
c'est exactement comme le code barres
d'un produit si je prends un produit à
l'épicerie je les scanne je sais
exactement qu'est ce qu'il ya dans
produit ici jeu puisque année la lumière
avec la spectroscopie serré la
correspond à du mercure dans cette
ampoule et deux pots de fluorescence le
terreau millions mais leurs pions je
peux dire donc sans me tromper que la
peau de droite et une fluocompacte et
l'impôt de gauche et une ampoule
incandescente
je vais vous le prouver je vais fermer
la lumière en fermant la lumière ou la
culture de spécial
ma femme sera pas content il y a des
coccinelles caché dans la lumière d'en
garder sa mémoire
si je réussis à fermer la lumière avec
une technique qu'elle quand je réussis à
voir quelque chose qui était pas visible
au départ quelque chose qui m'est bluey
c'est et en conclusion du cours de
spectroscopie
rappelez vous que le spectre nous
donnent l'indication chimique d'une
source de lumière tout simplement à peu
nous donner il peut nous donner beaucoup
d'autres enseignements mais pour
l'instant c'est pas utile
voici une étoile en 1995 deux astronomes
suisses ont sorti avec le télescope de
haute provence qu'ils ont équipé d'un
spectrographe et ils ont observé une
étoile bien précises 51 pegasi et ils
sont aperçus que les specs balancer
c'est bizarre c'est pas normal
normalement des specs arrêt dû être
relativement fixes ce qui veut dire que
les toilettes en mouvement
qu'est ce qui explique que les toilettes
en mouvement c'est parce qu'à une
planète qui tourne autour
ils ont été les premiers à gagner la
course qu'on avait depuis à peu près le
xviiie siècle les premiers à trouver une
exoplanète est une planète qui orbitent
autour d'une autre étoile
c'est ce qu'on appelle une exoplanète
cela ça veut dire que ça fait seulement
20 ans vous étiez tous nés dans la salle
quand qu'on a trouvé la première
exoplanète
mais depuis vingt ans on a mis lyon la
technologie on améliore les
spectrographes et maintenant on est
capable de trouver à l'époque ils ont
trouvé une planète géante qui était très
près de détroit qui faisait bouger
beaucoup l'étoile
maintenant on est capable de trouver des
planètes beaucoup plus petit de la
taille de la terre et situées beaucoup
plus loin donc on améliore on travaille
dessus
une autre technique pour trouver des
planètes c'est bien simple vous allez
comprendre facilement c'est comme je
fais une éclipse la planète passe devant
son étoile et pendant un certain temps
la luminosité diminue mais quand je dis
la luminosité diminue c'est légèrement
il faut pas les toits la disparue
paupières à paris c'est un dixième de 1%
quelquefois donc un 10 millièmes mais
c'est une vue d'artiste si on ne voit
pas les toiles on ne voit pas l'appeler
on voit le plein l'étoile on ne voit pas
la planète si je me place au niveau de
la terre voici ce que je vois c'est
simplement une source de lumière très
très très brillant qui diminue
légèrement donc rappeler que quand vous
voyez tout le temps dans l'est les
belles images de planète la télévision 6
tout temps des vues d'artiste c'est
exactement comme si j'essayais de voir
une fourmi sur un phare de voiture donc
il faut penser à ça mais au québec en
pas au québec mais
et on peut utiliser la même technique
pour voir beau plusieurs planètes
ici j'ai un système qu'on va sûrement
parler dans les journaux dans quelques
années qui les place en 86 aussi quand
où on voit cinq étoiles cinq planètes
qui tournent autour de son étoile donc
avec la même technique ont réussi à
faire en trouver plusieurs planètes
c'est quand même intéressant mais au
québec on a le vieil adage qui dit on
veut pas le savoir on veut le voir donc
une équipe internationale qui était
chapeautée par trois astrophysiciens
québécois ont réussi à prendre la
première photographie
le cpo inspecte ses pas on peut la voir
on pense qu'elles sont là non c'est une
première fuite aurait photographie ils
ont réussi à éteindre la lumière de
l'étoile par une technique de filtrage
pour qu'on puisse voir les quatre
planètes
c'est la première photographie prix en
2008 d'un système solaire autre que de
nous et ça s'est fait au québec c'est
exactement comme si j'essayais de voir
une luciole mais le chef pire il aurait
mangé mais bon nous nous on va s'il
l'utilisé
on va essayer de voir une luciole située
à 10 cm du phare de la place ville marie
avec notre télescope
mais notre télescope on va le placer à
toronto donc vous pouvez imaginer la
difficulté que cette image là a dû
prendre
et voici la vie d'artiste pour le
système que vous avez vu dans les
journaux mais la vraie photo c'est ça
ici notre dernière découverte à lire ex
l'irex l'institut de recherche sur les
exoplanètes de l'université de montréal
c'est une planète qui bat tous les
records deux mille années lumière
deux mille fois la distance terre soleil
ce qui veut dire qu'un an sur cette
planète
une rotation autour de son étoile prend
soixante mille ans 1 160 mille ans cuse
et donc un gouvernement sur cette
planète la est mort de rire s'il ya des
élections quatre ans ça nous donne six
cent quarante minutes d'austérité ada
depuis vingt ans nous avons environ 2000
exoplanètes d'identifier 2010 mais le
nombre est en train montrent vraiment la
vitesse grand v
ce qui veut dire que on peut estimer à
l'heure actuelle que pour chaque étoile
il y à au moins de deux à quatre
planètes il y à 300 milliards des toiles
seulement dans notre galaxie
pouvez vous imaginer le nombre de
planètes potentiel c'est incroyable mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec nos deux mille
étoiles
c'est quoi la prochaine étape est ce
qu'on peut imaginer
l'homme est en train de travailler pour
trouver pour fabriquer des instruments
pour trouver de la vie pour répondre à
la question sommes-nous seuls dans
l'univers
mais on pourra observer les 2000 planète
avec ses instruments dans le flou a
ciblé mais bonne planète pour
premièrement on va dire on va trouver de
la vie comme il ya sur la terre la terre
est une planète rocheuse donc dans nos
exoplanètes prenons seulement les
planètes rocheuses
deuxièmement notre vie est à base d'eau
on va essayer de trouver une planète qui
est située à la distance de son soleil
ou ce qu'on peut avoir de l'eau liquide
pas trop loin pas trop chaud pas trop
froide donc ce qu'on appelle la zone
habitable avec ses sept zones habitables
on peut aussi trouver des
planet géants comme jupiter qui pourrait
avoir une lune une lune qui a qui
pourraient être habitables sur la ligne
pour avoir de l'eau chaude vous l'avez
vu au cinéma avatar la lune pandora
était autour d'une planète géante menoua
l'irex on veut pas que ce soit juste du
cinéma on veut être les premiers à
pouvoir trouver une exo lune une lune
qui orbitent autour d'une autre planète
c'est exactement que je prends mon
exemple de lucioles c'est exactement
comme si j'essayais de voir une mouches
à fruits situé sur le dos de ma lucioles
donc c'est complexe mais c'est certain
qu'on va réussir à lyari dans notre
système solaire il ya trois planètes qui
ce qui peut avoir de l'eau liquide vénus
la terre est basse
d'ailleurs cet hiver il ya fait une
journée qui faisait plus chaud sur mars
qu'au québec
donc il a fait froid au québec
qu'est ce que je peux comment que je peu
différent c'est parce qu'il ya seulement
de la vie sur terre il n'y a pas de vie
sur mars mars a presque plus
d'atmosphère il n'y a pas de vie sur
vénus l'atmosphère de vénus
il ya un effet de serre incroyable donc
température 400 degrés peut pas voir
d'atmosphère ne peut pas avoir de vie
donc la clé c'est l'atmosphère
on va essayer de faire des instruments
qui vont essayer d'analysé de
l'atmosphère des planètes
il y à une ancienne ministre qui a dit
les vaches produisent autant d'effet de
serre que toute l'humanité
bon ok on va la prendre au mot et on va
essayer de les permettre de détecter des
gaz de vaches dans misery l'atmosphère
des exoplanètes
il n'y a pas encore d'instruments pour
ça on va lancer un instrument qu'on ne
travaille à l'université de montréal
avec le télescope james webb
il va partir normalement 2018
si tout va bien j'ai un souhait va être
le seul instrument capable de faire un
suspect pour avoir comme on a vu au
début la composition chimique de
l'atmosphère
donc il va observer une étoile et
qu'est-ce qui va obtenir
bon il nettoie ses traits lumineux mais
on a la technique maintenant pour fermer
la lumière il va réussir peut-être avoir
deux planeurs on ne sait pas nos deux
planètes du début que je vous montrais
dans le petit vidéo la planète géant et
notre planète qui contient et comme la
terre et on espère parce que c'est une
simulation pouvoir trouver la vie comme
ça si je regarde la planète géant la
signature seulement du méthane
probablement qui a pas de vie sur cette
planète là c'est certain
seulement du métal mais l'autre planète
on a en plus dû mettant dans l'eau de
l'oxygène de l'eau de l'ozone et du
dioxyde de carbone l'oxygène est un bio
marqueur
imaginez si j'élimine toute forme de vie
sur terre
je tue tous les bactéries je tue tout
tout tout dans quelques années il y aura
plus d'oxygène tout l'oxygène beau se
mélanger dans ce hall brouiller la
planète terre au lieu d'être la planète
bleue va devenir une planète rouge comme
la planète mars donc l'oxygène et un
biomarqueur mais c'est pas le seul
biomarqueurs parce qu'on peut le produit
un petit peu de façon naturelle
mais si je combine avec de l'eau si je
combine avec un peu de méthane donc le
gaz de mes vaches ou plutôt des
bactéries qui décomposent la matière si
j'ai un peu de gaz carbonique
je suis pratiquement sûr que j'ai une
forme de vie sur cette planète
est ce que la vie est intelligent est ce
que la vie n'est pas un ailier seulement
bactérien
ce sera une autre état mais j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir vous répondre
intimement lâche pas seulement pour moi
je crois que d'ici 30 1 on va voir la
réponse sommes-nous seuls dans l'univers
et moi je crois que
la réponse est non sauf peut-être que
james webb a démontré on espère pour
l'instant de dix planètes qui sont
potentiellement habitables dix planètes
tout ce qu'on peut avoir de la ville
est-ce que ça va fonctionner je sais pas
mais jusqu'à ce moment sur que sa voix
est l'irex l'institut de recherche de
l'université de montréal qui va vous
donner la réponse
et d'ailleurs on accepte les subventions
privées
merci merci monsieur turbide